rich is on the line in Canada hi rich
how are you good thank you thank you for
taking my call Dave big fan of the show
thank you how can I help
I'm looking for your opinion or your
opinion on my financial situation I
don't have any other debt except for a
mortgage on my personal home which is
rather large and mortgages on investment
properties and a line of credit that was
used as the down payment for those
investment properties so I'm feeling a
little bit uncomfortable in a sense even
though those investment properties um
for the most part cashflow positive
I'm just looking for opinion what I
should do is sell those properties to
pay off my mortgage on my personal home
or a much do on your personal home about
520 okay and how much equity is in these
rental properties total uh if you sold a
mile if you sold them all how big a pile
of money would be in the table uh
probably about I'm thinking about 270
okay and that's after the line of credit
and everything's paid yeah after
everything so how much is the line of
credit about two hundred twenty-six okay
and um how many properties are there the
rentals three three okay and what is
your household income about 240,000 oh
that's awesome
okay well the good news is you have a li
in Canada yeah the good news is you have
a wonderful income bad news is you do
have an awful lot of debt a lot of debt
and so um you know I I'm probably I love
and I love the rentals I mean I love
rental property you know that if you
listen to me I own a bunch of it yeah
and I'm a big fan of real estate but I
pay cash for it obviously so you know
the question I guess you could ask
yourself is what if you owed $250,000 on
your house and you had no rental
properties would you go borrow $250,000
on your house and go into debt to buy
all these rental properties if you
didn't already own them uh yeah I guess
in a sense I would be
I'm looking at these investment offices
kind of like my retirement okay my nest
egg great then you needed then you need
to start aggressively paying down
something and I probably would start
with the line of credit and then I would
pick out a rental property and pay it
off another one pay it off and maybe
start paying on the house you know but
you've got this wonderful income to be
able to knock through it how much is
owed on the three properties um whatever
they think about seven hundred thousand
probably because she got 1 million five
how long is it going to take you to walk
through that with making 240 at this
rate we're just in the I guess we kind
of live a pretty expensive life so we
don't have a lot of you know a lot of
extra savings at the end of it at the
end of each month with you know with the
kids and you're heavily leveraged if
you're if you can't walk out these
things pretty dadgum quick you need to
start talking about shutting yourself if
some of them are all of them yeah
because you're going to trip and fall if
you don't and you're making too good of
money to end up broke and you know you
got that coming out your ears you got
million dollars on three properties
that's a lot that's a lot and on rentals
and I get you know you got a nice income
but it's going to get sucked up by this
stuff so I'm probably dumping at least
one or two of them maybe all three of
them if I were in your shoes and then
let's get back to solid ground let's get
your house paid off hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income
you